j'ai fait une soirée je suis déchire man
j'ai donc c'est ce qu'à 7 heures du
matin jeudi schirmann bechiri ses 11 ans
deux bébés soir à tous et merci d'être
avec nous d'être en direct alors je vous
le dis on fait un petit anniversaire
aujourd'hui c'est un mini anniversaire
pourquoi parce que on l'a vu dans les
archives on l'a vu dans l'émission de
benjamin castaldi
ce qui nous manque le plus c'est le
mythique le public donc beaucoup à cette
émission vous nous manquer énormément
les cherry et on a hâte de vous
retrouver et sachez le si il ya
possibilité qu'on se retrouve avant la
fin de la saison on fera un énorme prime
avec du public avec des dark à avec des
bus avec des duplex avec une grosse
soirée à la fin on le fera avec vous mes
chéris ouais
[Applaudissements]
et voilà
ne mettez pas de musique vous savez que
je parte chez vous le savez je pars au
quart de tour les chéris avec la musique
je suis un jeune sur belgrade
je suis un bédouin série que vous nous
manquer énormément et j'espère qu'on va
pouvoir faire cette soirée de ouf et qui
fait un peu